[Music]
there's no disputing that shenzhen has
become one of the most important places
in the world of tech
nowhere else has quite as potent a
combination of tech know-how
cheap manufacturing costs and sheer
speed
but it goes further than that living in
shenzhen is in many ways
like living in the future and not
necessarily
a utopian future more like
the other kind
[Music]
consider zowie
zowie operates a factory much like any
other in shenzhen
they make cheap smartphones and other
electronics
like other top manufacturers they've
built a complex where workers can live
right beside the factory line
work around the clock for a couple of
years and hopefully buy a better life
for their families back home
the factories here are clean and the
work is precise
but things are changing quickly in a way
that does not favor the common man and
woman
all the rest of these lines are staffed
by about 80 people
but right here there's new machines
coming online that are going to build a
smartphone
end to end completely by robots
the end goal of something like this is
to get the quality of the product higher
to bring costs down from less labor and
ultimately to keep china as the
manufacturing hub of the world
and fend off low price competition for
places like southeast asia
the factory of the future looks like
this
it's a closed off loop where robots pass
components among each other
and finished products pop out at the end
all those workers have been replaced by
one lonely
final inspector
it's a strong sign that the future of
shenzhen is less for these guys
and more for these guys
zowie actually builds these automation
machines itself
behind me are some of china's best and
brightest engineers
hard at work building the machines you
see out on the floor today
and the ones that are coming tomorrow
that are going to automate the entire
factory line
[Music]
nowhere will face more turmoil than
shenzhen as the robots rise
and send millions of workers to the
unemployment line
[Music]
but it's not just the working class
that's facing a dark future
there are dystopian innovations that
seem to touch every
facet of life here
i ran into one example of this while
attempting to rehydrate
doesn't work i don't know okay
after some investigation i discover
what's going on here
and it has to do with these things qr
codes you know the drill
you scan the code and something pops up
on your phone
like a promotion or discount america
laughed these things off years ago
but here they run the entire economy
cash and credit cards are history
instead
you scan qr codes to pay for everything
restaurants groceries
even buskers
on the surface this is all good it's the
easy convenient
mobile payment system of the future
but there's also a dark side
the chinese government can peer into the
two dominant payment systems
alipay and wechat as it sees fit
it's already started tracking behavior
as part of a plan to rank citizens
and measure how good and obedient they
are
the tech revolution may have brought
prosperity to shenzhen
but it's also brought more and more
insidious intrusions into people's lives
to dig deeper into life under the
chinese deep state
i've assembled a team of extraordinary
foreigners who work at tech startups in
shenzhen
hopefully a few beers will encourage
them to open up
about their thought crimes living in a
very tightly regulated communist country
does that bother you or you don't care
like the presumption at least that i got
before i came from australia you're sort
of like
moving into sort of like a militarized
state kind of thing like things are
gonna be really intense but like you
take a beer just like walk down the road
hang out in the park
fine yeah do that back in my hometown
australia like
straight to the cup house but then place
spike ball
on the grass oh yeah and then all of a
sudden the cops come and struggle
you got you jaywalked and you had facial
recognition
i actually got this yeah so i was i was
uh jaywalking and dan chan
and all of a sudden i gotta find to my
my wechat
was it interesting it was it was uh
about two twenty twenty seconds after i
get to you i
have money in my balance it just went
straight out and this is just the worst
thing you didn't you just came straight
out of an authorized that was incredible
that's crazy
it's true try to jaywalk in certain
parts of shenzhen
and the government's facial recognition
will spot you
there's even a board of shame showing
the faces of recent offenders
[Music]
i'm surprised and very very worried that
they have your face in the facial record
like facial recognition they have
everyone so i mean when you get across
the border
yeah exactly yeah so it's all in the
system they know where you are
it gets even scarier because big brother
is watching what you do
online too most of the websites we know
and love are blocked in china
replaced with chinese equivalents that
the government can monitor
a sort of mirror universe internet
i asked my friend diane a shenzhen
native
to help break this down appropriately
enough
she took me to this restaurant staffed
entirely by robots that's some gnarly
looking chicken is that chicken
robot food i wanted you to help me out
with one thing so if i
sort of call out a u.s tech company can
you tell me
the chinese equivalent because you know
you can't get instagram or anything here
so let's do a few
uh google would be right
and amazon it's like both jd.com and
also
uh taobao okay and and
um youtube uh you're cool you're cool
ity
facebook facebook we have wechat wechat
yeah yeah
yeah do you feel like you're in a
different universe all the online stuff
is such a big part of all our lives and
it seems like china has created its own
right world
yeah that's definitely like that um
but like i said for for like instagram i
was surprised to see even
instagram got banned from china but all
the young people they're
there still go yeah
[Music]
it turns out it is possible to access
the freedom loving internet here
via what's called a vpn an alternate
internet connection
that bypasses the government's blocks
and you don't get in trouble if they see
that you're on the vpn all the time
for personal use i don't think that's
like is that a big deal yeah
a feature will be interesting for how
the the different world like
collaborating together
yeah and definitely the young generation
they're they're not like just oh i'm
satisfied i just kind of
stay inside okay yeah they're more
curious
[Music]
i came to shenzhen hoping to find some
kind of ground truth
a clear picture of what china's growing
tech prowess
will mean for the rest of us
honestly though i'm as confused as ever
the city is full of energy desire and
creativity
but exactly how those traits are
channeled in the years ahead
remains an open question
my hope is that the best parts of our
human nature get a chance to thrive
and that 1984 can wait a few more
decades to arrive
[Music]
and on that note i leave you with this
dashboard dog
because it's obviously good and pure and
very happy
thanks for watching and if you want to
see more hello world click on the link
to subscribe
you